Ok so promethium is actually my least favourite
lanthanide because I
can’t actually work with it. It’s highly
radioactive and at any one time on
the earth’s surface there is not an awful
lot of it so you can’t physically
get enough of it to do any chemistry with.
So promethium is the only one of the rare
earth elements that is
radioactive, but because it’s radioactive
and the atoms decay away it’s
not found in nature. So it was only after
the start of nuclear research
that people discovered promethium, even some
of the products from the
decay from other radioactive elements. And
you can see this quite well:
this is an old chemistry book that I’ve
got, written by Aston, the famous
scientist who discovered isotopes – atoms
of the same element that have
different weights - and in this book which
he published in 1922…
Hold it a bit more vertical. Ok go ahead.
…he had a periodic table and if you look
down here, here are the rare
earths and in this position here there is
a space for element 61,
promethium. So element 61 wasn’t known in
1922 and it was found
much later. But you can see the rest of the
elements were, except
there’s a gap down here under tungsten because,
again, the element
rhenium was only discovered relatively recently
compared to most of the
other elements.